ce sont des signes qui ne trompent pas
les petits fours des visages tendus et
une ambiance sérieuse attrape ils
étaient une quarantaine à s'être réunis
pour suivre le débat entre leur champion
et manuel valls
finalement ils les ont assisté à un duel
cordiale économie laïcité sécurité ou
encore environnement ont permis aux
finalistes est exposé leur vision de la
gauche
nous ne pouvons plus tolérer ou non de
nos enfants que nos modes de production
et nos modes de consommation mettent en
péril la planète
ce futur désirable il ne dépend que
d'eux de le faire gagner
c'est le sens de ma candidature mais
alors qui sort vainqueur du débat
voilà le réel enjeu de cette soirée dans
le fief électoral du député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines et il n'y
avait qu'un vainqueur et par ko nouvelle
fois on a parlé de ses propositions
parce qu'ils aient travaillé avec
sérieux depuis de longs mois
il est pas con idée depuis le mois
décembre connu et le bâti et depuis le
mois de doute ou de juillet oui un vrai
clivage mais entre un projet qui quelque
part ressasse
et des mots d'un système à bout de
souffle et puis bah un projet qui pense
le monde de demain
reste à savoir désormais si ce clivage
et ces différences pourront être
dépassés le soir du dimanche 29 janvier
la question du rassemblement est en
effet moins évidente chez les militants
de benoît hamon
si c'est légal baa3 mieux pour lui mais
je pense que benoît hamon en quelques
années il se présentera peut-être la
présidentielle pourquoi pas benoît hamon
une meilleur candidat à la fois pour
rapport rassembler la gauche et les
sympathisants socialistes mais
rassemblée après après cette primaire
rassembler l'ensemble de la gauche
il est capable de parler aussi bien jean
luc mélenchon cas pierre laurent et
yannick jadot et à tous les électeurs de
gauche
nouvelle étape ce soir avant le résultat
des urnes les deux candidats sont en
meeting en ile-de-france manuel valls à
alfortville et benoît hamon à montreuil